satisfaction is the joy you get after
struggle but the real riddle about
satisfaction is that you mother nature
tells us that if you get it it's going
to last and it doesn't Mick Jagger says
I Can't Get No Satisfaction that's wrong
if you couldn't get it you wouldn't keep
trying and trying and trying like the
song goes the problem is you can't keep
No Satisfaction and that's the thing
that you never quite figure out and we
understand the brain science behind that
but but we have to once again we have to
diverge from Mother Nature's teachings
or Mother Nature's urges that she gives
us and do something on the Divine path
and and if we do certain things that
feel quite unnatural we can make
satisfaction stick around